It's useful to talk to people that you
don't agree with and it's.
It's useful for a variety of reasons.
One is that a lot of what determines
your political orientation is biological
temperament far more than people
realize.
So for example,
left leaning people liberals,
let's say,
although that's kind of Miss Misnomer,
but we'll keep with the terminology.
Liberals are high in a trait called
openness,
which is one of the big five personality
traits and it's associated with interest
in abstraction and interest in
aesthetics.
It's the best predictor of liberal
political leaning and they're low in
trait conscientiousness,
which is due to fullness and and
orderliness in particular.
Whereas the conservatives,
so the opposite.
They're high in conscientiousness there
due to full in orderly and they're low
in openness and that makes them really
good.
Managers and administers ministers and
often businessmen but not very good
entrepreneurs because entrepreneurs are
almost all drawn from the liberal types
and so these are really fundamental
fundamentally biologically predicated
differences.
And there you might think about them as
different sets of,
of,
of opportunities and limitations and
certainly different ways of screening
the world and each of those different
temperamental types needs the other
type.
So economically speaking,
for example,
we need liberals to start businesses and
we need conservatives to run them and
the conservatives are too conservative,
so if they are running businesses,
they have a bitch of a time with
innovation.
Whereas the liberals are really good at
generating new ideas and and moving
laterally,
but they're not very good at the level
of detail and implementation.
And so if you start understanding that
the person.
This is a diversity issue,
let's call this a diversity issue,
if you start understanding that the
person that you're talking to doesn't
share your political views,
isn't stupid,
that's the first thing necessarily.
They might be,
but so might you be no,
stupidity isn't the differences in
intelligence are not the prime
determinant of differences in political
belief.
All right?
So you might be talking to someone who's
more conscientious and less creative
than you.
If you're,
if you happen to be a liberal,
but that doesn't mean that that person's
perspective is not valid and it doesn't
mean that they wouldn't outperform you
in some domains because they would.
So one thing to remember is people
actually do see the world differently.
It's not merely that they,
that they're possessed of ill informed
opinions.
So you have to first of all,
stretch out your hand and say,
look,
you know,
like,
I,
I get that you see the world differently
than me and I also understand that
there's a place for you and to place for
me even though that isn't the same
place.
And then it's necessary to also remember
that,
well,
do you want to talk to people or do you
want it?
Do you want to fight with them?
Because fighting is not pleasant and it
goes very dark places very,
very rapidly.
And so,
you know,
the last time I was down in Boston,
I talked to an old friend of mine and
this person went on a relatively,
um,
solid and strong and relatively personal
critique of,
of trump supporters calling them ill
informed and stupid.
And you know,
and insulting and insulting
characterization.
And I thought,
well it was surprising to me because
this was a reasonable person and I think
it was an indication of the
polarization,
but you know,
you can't throw away 50 percent of the
population like that.
It's not reasonable.
And it's the same on the right.
The Conservatives can't do it to the
liberals either.
I mean,
right now I think that the radical left
totalitarian proclivity is a much
greater danger than radical right?
Totalitarian proclivity,
especially on the university campuses.
And so I've been mostly speaking out
about the,
about the leftwing radicals.
It could've just as easily been the
reverse case.
It just doesn't happen to me.
But you.
The whole point of the,
of a democracy is to continue the
dialogue between people of different
temperamental types so that we don't
move so far to the right,
that everything becomes encapsulated in
stone and doesn't move or so far to the
left and everything dissolves in a kind
of a mealy mouth chaos.
And the only way that you can,
you can navigate between those two shows
is by,
is through discussion,
which is why free speech is such an
important value.
It's the thing that keeps the
temperamental types from being at each
other's throats,
just like in a marriage,
you know,
because there's differences in the
marriage.
If you can't talk you either you're
either subservient or you fight.
Well that's no good.
So.
So part of it is have some respect for
people that are different than you,
which is of course what the radical
leftists are saying,
but they don't identify the real
differences.